when france fell to germany in may 1940
britain was left standing alone
well sort of alone alone in the sense of
it was only britain and all of its
empire remaining in the fight
irrespective the united kingdom's
position at that point wasn't exactly
enviable and there were many politicians
there who thought the fighting on was
foolish
so given britain's outlook at this point
this raises the question
why didn't britain make peace after the
fall of france so as you know
1940 saw the german invasion of denmark
norway the benelux region and france and
to put him mildly things didn't go well
for the allies
after the fall of norway britain's prime
minister neville chamberlain was under a
lot of pressure to resign and there were
two candidates to succeed him
lord halifax who said no thus narrowing
it down to only one candidate winston
churchill during this time the british
government was divided as to whether or
not it should continue the war
so far things hadn't exactly gone well
and the odds only seemed to be getting
worse and worse
this was mostly because france was
faring poorly at this point
which through the british strategy of
letting the french get punched in the
face until britain could harm and train
up an army of about one and a half
million men and send them to the
continent
which was planned for about 1942 with
france about to fall lord halifax pushed
to make peace and negotiate fire
mussolini's government this wasn't
because halifax thought that britain was
going to be conquered or mostly put in
charge or something but because he
didn't think that any victory was worth
a world war one style war of attrition
as you'll know halifax's proposals went
nowhere but why was that the case
there were several reasons the first was
that churchill and many
in government didn't trust any treaty
that hitler was willing to sign
furthermore one of germany's conditions
for peace was the return of its former
african and asian colonies which was not
something that the allies were willing
to countenance
the second reason was that british
military leadership was confident that
they could at worst push germany to a
stalemate
and at best last until the german
economy collapsed just like in world war
one
so for them it was simply a case of
keeping public morale up and not
bankrupt in the country by keeping the
sea lanes open
this opinion was solidified when italy
joined the war and but it decided to
focus on italy the idea being that just
like austria-hungary in the last world
war germany would constantly have to
bail them out
the third reason was that britain was
confident that germany would eventually
do something silly like invade the
soviet union or do something that would
pull the united states into the war this
wasn't due to some hunch but because
britain and polish code breakers had
heard it from the germans themselves
and to help secure support from the us
britain was sure to fight the war on as
many fronts as possible
for example by quickly sending troops to
greece when it was invaded this wasn't
because they thought they could stop its
fool but because it made it clear that
they were the ones defending smaller
nations independence were on the side of
international stability
which would indirectly put pressure on
american politicians to eventually do
something
britain's leadership didn't believe that
it could conventionally defeat germany
but that it simply had to hold out until
about 1942 until germany made a mistake
which it did in 1941 and soon afterwards
its ally japan did the same
bringing two monumental allies into the
conflict and tipping the scales
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with a special
thanks to my patrons
james bissonette kelly money maker
marvin cassal mo aaron the white
james castaneda marcus arsenal jordan
longley gustav swann rasheed ali
jerry lambda maggie patzkowski
coppertone winston k wood spencer
lightfoot robert wetzel spinning three
plates caution wolf matthew shipley
anthony beckett and charles the first